ها المهله المعطاه للموظفين الحكوميين
الامريكيين لحجب تيك توك من هواتفهم يعود
التركيز على المخاطر الامنيه التي يشكلها
التطبيق الصيني الاشهر فعلى الرغم من
الحرب في اوكرانيا احتلت الصين معظم
المناقشات عندما اطلع رؤساء وكاله
الاستخبارات البلاد المشرعين على
التهديدات الرئيسيه للولايات المتحده
النقاش تركز بالطبع على نقاط الضعف غير
العسكريه للولايات المتحده تجاه الصين فما
هي نقاط الضعف هذه يجيبنا رئيس تحرير قسم
التكنولوجيا والعلوم في موقع ديفنس ون
بالتاكيد يمكننا القاء نظره على بعض
الامثله لسرقه الملكيه الفكريه واعاده
استخدامها الصين سرقت الملكيه الفكريه
للمسيرات العسكريه الامريكيه وصنعت مسيره
لها مما جعل الولايات المتحده تضطر الى
اعاده تصميم جوانب جديده في هذا البرنامج
الولايات المتحده تخسر مليارات الدولارات
في الملكيه الفكريه العسكريه وفي القطاع
الخاص ايضا
يقول ان التيك توك يهدد امن وخصوصيه
الامريكيين مضيفا ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
قد يخترق هواتف الامريكيين باستخدام
التطبيق الامر الذي يحتم وضع ضوابط للتاكد
من عدم تحوله الى اداه تجسس تهدد امن
وخصوصيه الامريكيين
بحذف الموظفين الحكوميين لتطبيق تيك توك
على هواتفهم يبقى الامل بوقف تسريب
البيانات الحاليه هناك الكثير من
المعلومات التي يمكن لتطبيق تيك توك ان
يستخرجها من الهاتف وبعض رجال الاستخبارات
يعتبر انه من الافضل التخلص من الهواتف
التي كان عليها التطبيق وليس فقط التخلص
وحذف
التطبيقات من الصين لكن التحدي الهائل
يكمن في اقناع الامريكيين بالتهديد الذي
يشكله تيك توك خاصه وان بعض المجموعات
التي تدعم حريه التعبير والحريات المدنيه
تعارض هذه الخطوه مستشهده بالتعديل الاول
العربيه واشنطن